TO SAY TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IG
REPORT OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪
>> Sean: I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT BEFORE WE GET INTO
THE CONTENTS OF THIS REPORT
THAT WE'RE ALL GOING TO
BREAK DOWN NUT COURSE OF
THIS HOUR.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND SOMETHING.
THIS IS SADLY A SWAMP
DOCUMENT.
NOW, THE SWAMP ALWAYS
PROTECTS THE SWAMP.
UNFORTUNATELY AND IN
REALITY, BEFORE WE EVEN GET
STARTED, LET ME JUST REMIND
YOU OF SOMETHING I SAID LAST
NIGHT.
THE FACTS IN THIS CASE ARE
NOT IN DISPUTE.
THE EVIDENCE IS OVERWHELMING
AND CONVERTIBLE.
HILLARY VIOLATED THE
ESPIONAGE ACT.
THAT'S A FACT.
SHE MISHANDLED.
SHE DESTROYED CLASSIFIED-TOP
SECRET SPECIAL ACCESS
PROGRAMMING INFORMATION.
IT'S A FACT.
SHE DELETE YOU HAD 33,000
SUBPOENAED EMAILS.
SHE ACID WASHED HER HARD
DRIVE WITH BLEACH BIT SO
THEY COULDN'T GET FACTS.
SHE HAD AIDES DESTROY HER
MOBILE DEVICES WITH HAMMERS
ALSO A FACT.
HERE IS ANOTHER FACT
CHRISTIAN
KRRISTIAN
KRISSTIAN
KRISTIIAN
KRISTIANN
KRISTIAN SAUCIER SPENT A
YEAR IN PRISON FOR, WHAT,
SIX PICTURES ON A CELL PHONE
AT A SUBMARINE THAT HE WAS
PROUD HE WORKED ON.
HE NEVER SHARED IT WITH
ANYBODY.
SO, IN TERMS OF SEVERITY, IT
DOESN'T COMPARE TO WHAT WE
KNOW HILLARY CLINTON DID.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT COMEY AND
TRUMP HATER PETER STRZOK
STARTED WRITING HER
EXONERATION IN EARLY MAY OF
2016.
THAT'S A FACT.
THEY WILL DIDN'T INTERVIEW
HER UNTIL JULY 2ND 2016 AND
THEN JULY 5TH THEY
EXONERATED HER WE KNOW THEY
PULLED THE LEGAL DEFINITION
OF GROSS NEGLIGENCE, THEY
PULLED IT RIGHT OUT OF
DOCUMENT.
THEY PULLED OUT IN ONE OF
THEIR EARLIER WRITINGS IN
THIS THAT, IN FACT, FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES HAD
HACKED INTO THAT BATHROOM
CLOSET.
ALL A FACT.
EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN
TONIGHT YOU SHOULD BE
SHOCKED, YOU SHOULD BE
DISAPPOINTED, YOU SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
LEARNING.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ABUSE OF
POWER AND CORRUPTION AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE FBI.
AND HOW THE FBI WAS
POLITICIZED.
IT'S ALL TRUE AND WE HAVE A
LOT OF NEW EVIDENCE WE'LL
SHARE WITH YOU TONIGHT.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR AT
THE START.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT RANK
AND FILE FBI GUYS.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THEM.
I PREDICT BY THE TIME THIS
STORY ENDS, THEY WILL END UP
BEING THE HEROES WHEN
THEY'RE FINALLY SUBPOENAED
AND ALLOWED TO TESTIFY AND
TELL THEIR STORIES ABOUT
WHAT THEY SAW THEIR BOSSES
WERE DOING.
AND TONIGHT WE'LL HIGHLIGHT
THE STARK DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
TWO INVESTIGATIONS.
YOU GET THE WHITE GLOVE
SPECIAL TREATMENT FOR
HILLARY CLINTON AND THEN THE
HEAVY HANDED TACTICS ALL IN
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
IT SHOULD SHOCK YOU.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR
LAWS AND OUR CONSTITUTION.
NOW, WITH HILLARY CLINTON,
EVERYONE WAS GIVEN IMMUNITY.
WITH DONALD TRUMP, IT'S
SEARCH WARRANTS, SUBPOENAS,
BREAKING DOWN DOORS AT 6:00
A.M., GUNS ABLAZED.
THE HATRED OF DONALD TRUMP
FROM THE LEFT IN THE MEDIA
IN THIS COUNTRY KNOWS NO
BOUNDS.
THERE REALLY WAS A SCHEME TO
PROTECT HILLARY RODHAM
CLINTON FROM BEING INDICTED
AND SMEAR AND SLANDER THEN
CANDIDATE, THEN
PRESIDENT-ELECT DONALD TRUMP
AND NOW PRESIDENT AT ALL
COSTS.
NOW THE CONTEMPT FOR YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE THING THAT SOME OF THESE
PEOPLE SAID ABOUT US, YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IS
REPUGNANT, IT'S APPALLING.
IT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
NOW, TO THE REPORT.
AS I JUST SAID, IT'S
AS I JUST SAID, ITSS
AS I JUST SAID, ITS FINDINGS
CONFIRM PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU HERE ON HANNITY
FOR MONTHS AND THAT MANY IN
THE MEDIA HAVE IGNORED.
WE HAVE TREY GOWDY SUMMED IT
UP VERY WELL.
HE SAID, QUOTE:  I AM
ALARMED, ANGERED AND DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTED BY THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S FINDINGS
OF NUMEROUS FAILURES BY THE
DUONG AND FBI IN
INVESTIGATING POTENTIAL
ESPIONAGE ACT VIOLATIONS BY
THE FORMER SECRETARY OF
STATE HILLARY CLINTON.
WITHOUT FURTHER DISCUSSION,
HERE'S WHAT GOWDY IS TALKING
ABOUT.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, WE START
WITH DISGRACED FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY.
NOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP FIRED
COMEY FOR MISHANDLING THE
CLINTON SERVER INVESTIGATION
AMONG OTHER REASONS.
HE WILL DESERVED TO BE
FIRED.
TONIGHT, THE PRESIDENT IS
VINDICATED.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FINDS
IN THIS REPORT JAMES COMEY'S
ACTIONS WERE BOTH
EXTRAORDINARY AND
INSUBORDINATE.
HIS INVESTIGATION INTO
HILLARY CLINTON DEVIATED
FROM WELL-ESTABLISHED
DEPARTMENT POLICIES.
NOW, THIS INCLUDES COMEY AND
OTHER FBI AGENTS ALLOWING
CLINTON AIDE AND WITNESSES
TO THE INVESTIGATION, CHERYL
MILLS, TO ACTUALLY SIT IN
DURING HILLARY CLINTON'S FBI
INTERVIEW.
AN INTERVIEW THAT TOOK PLACE
AFTER COMEY HAD ALREADY
DRAFTED A LETTER EXONERATING
HILLARY OF ALL CHARGES.
AND THERE'S MORE.
THE REPORT ALSO FINDS THAT
WHILE INVESTIGATING HILLARY
CLINTON FOR CONDUCTING
OFFICIAL GOVERNMENT
BUSINESS, WITH A PRIVATE
EMAIL ACCOUNT, WHOA, JAMES
COMEY WAS ALSO USING A
PRIVATE EMAIL ACCOUNT TO
CONDUCT OFFICIAL GOVERNMENT
BUSINESS.
AND BY THE WAY COMEY
RESPONDED ON TWITTER
WRITING, QUOTE:  I RESPECT
THE DOJ IG OFFICE.
WHICH IS WHY I URGED THEM TO
DO THIS REVIEW.
THE CONCLUSIONS ARE
REASONABLE, EVEN THOUGH I
DISAGREE WITH SOME.
PEOPLE OF GOOD FAITH CAN SEE
AN UNPRECEDENTED DECISION.
I PRAY NO DIRECTOR FACES IT
AGAIN.
THANKS TO IG'S PEOPLE FOR
HARD WORK.
LET'S BREAK THIS DOWN.
JAMES COMEY, THE FBI
DIRECTOR WENT ROGUE.
THERE IS NO OTHER
CONCLUSION.
HE BROKE LONG STANDING
DEPARTMENT POLICY LITERALLY
WRITING THE EXONERATION OF
HILLARY CLINTON BEFORE EVER
INTERVIEWING HER OR 17 OTHER
KEYENS WITHS.
CLOSED UP THE INVESTIGATION.
AND IMMEDIATELY THE SAME
PEOPLE THIS HATED TRUMP THAT
WE NOW KNOW AND WE'LL PROVE
IT IN MORE DETAIL, THE SAME
PEOPLE LITTLELY BEGIN THE
EXONERATION OF DONALD TRUMP.
THEY EXONERATED HER BACK IN
MAY.
INTERVIEW HER JULY 2ND,
JULY 5TH SHE IS EXONERATED.
SAME PEOPLE THAT COMMITTED
THE SAME MISDEEDS AS CLINTON
THEY WERE INVESTIGATED AND
PUT IN JAIL.
THAT'S WHY COMEY WAS FIRED
AROUND SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATED FURTHER.
THAT'S NOT ALL.
NOW WE HAVE EVEN MORE
EVIDENCE TO SHOW HOW FBI
AGENTS MISHANDLED THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE IG
REPORT.
AGENTS INVOLVED IN THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION
INVESTIGATION, GET THIS:
THEY WERE INSTRUCTED TO TAKE
NO OVERT INVESTIGATIVE STEPS
PRIOR TO THE ELECTION.
AND THE REPORT ALSO
CONFIRMED THAT WHILE THE FBI
WAS TIPTOEING AROUND THEIR
FAVORITE CANDIDATE, HILLARY
CLINTON, WHO THEY FULLY
THOUGHT WOULD WIN THE
ELECTION, CLINTON'S PRIVATE
SERVER WAS BEING ACCESSED BY
FOREIGN ACTORS.
OH, THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE
THAT THEY TOOK OUT.
AND, REMEMBER THE FBI TRUMP
HATING LOVE BIRDS STRZOK AND
PAGE.
THEY ARE BACK AND BACK IN A
BIG WAY TONIGHT.
HEAVILY FEATURED IN
HOROWITZ'S REPORT HOROWITZ
UNBELIEVABLY, THIS IS
OUTRAGEOUS DID, NOT FIND
THAT BIAS IMPACTED THE FBI
INVESTIGATION U LOOK AT THIS
UNCOVERED TEXT MESSAGE.
THE DATE, AUGUST 8TH, 2016,
PAGE IT CLAIMS TRUMP IS
NEVER GOING TO BECOME
PRESIDENT, RIGHT?
RIGHT?
AND STRZOK RESPONDS, QUOTE:
NO.
NO, HE'S NOT.
WE'LL STOP IT.
IN CASE YOU ARE WONDERING
WHAT STRZOK IS TALKING
ABOUT.
HE'S MAKING IT CRYSTAL CLEAR
IN THIS TWEET FROM A MONTH
EARLIER IN JULY OF 2016.
DAMN, THIS FEELS MOMENTOUS
BECAUSE THIS MATTERS.
THE OTHER ONE DID, TOO.
MEANING THE INVESTIGATION
INTO CLINTON.
BUT THAT WAS TO ENSURE WE
DIDN'T BLEEP SOMETHING UP.
THIS MATTERS BECAUSE THIS
MATTERS.
SO SUPER GLAD TO BE ON THIS
VOYAGE WITH YOU.
AND OF COURSE STRZOK IS
TALKING ABOUT THE IMPENDING
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION INTO
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
COMPARING IT TO THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION WHICH HE TRIED
SO HARD NOT TO SCREW UP
BECAUSE IT WAS HIS EFFORT TO
CLEAR HILLARY CLINTON OF ALL
CHARGES SO SHE COULD REMAIN
A CANDIDATE.
THE FAVORED CANDIDATE.
DON'T FORGET ABOUT THE
INSURANCE POLICY THAT WAS
WITH
RETH
REFERENCED IN PREVIOUS PAGE
STRZOK TEXTS IF IN FACT
TRUMP WON THE ELECTION.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT ALL OF THIS
TOOK PLACE AROUND EXTREME
LEVELS OF APPEAR AT THIS
TRUMP BIAS AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF FBI.
SOME OF IT SHOULD SHOCK THE
CONSCIENCE.
PAGE CALLING TRUMP ENORMOUS
D BAG AND ADD THAT THE TO
LIST OF INSULTS BOTH PAGE
AND STRZOK WERE LOBBYING
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP CALLING
HIM AN IDIOT.
A MENACE, A LOATHE SOME
HUMAN BEING AND SO MUCH
MORE.
STRZOK IS THE GUY LEADING
ALL OF THIS INVESTIGATION.
THEN THE REPORT CONCLUDED
ABOUT THESE TEXTS, QUOTE:
NOT ONLY INDICATIVE OF A
BIASED STATE OF MIND, BUT
EVEN MORE SERIOUSLY IMPLIES
A WILLINGNESS TO TAKE
OFFICIAL ACTION TO IMPACTED
THE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE'S
ELECTORAL PROSPECTS.
YEAH, THAT'S POLITICAL.
LISA PAGE BY THE WAY CALLED
TRUMP AS WE SAID BEFORE, WE
WON'T GO BACK TO THAT AND
THEN THE IG FOUND EVIDENCE
OF SO MUCH MORE BIAS AMONG
FBI OFFICIALS, FOR EXAMPLE,
LOOK AT THIS MESSAGE FROM
ONE UNNAMED AGENT, QUOTE:
TRUMP SUPPORTERS BY THE WAY
THAT'S YOU.
ARE ALL POOR TO MIDDLE
CLASS, UNEDUCATED, LAZY,
POSS, WE KNOW WHAT THAT IS
THAT THINK HE WILL MAGICALLY
GRANT THEM JOBS FOR DOING
NOTHING.
ON OCTOBER 28TH, 2016,
SHORTLY AFTER COMEY'S LETTER
TO CONGRESS, THAT ANNOUNCED
THE REOPENING OF THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION, ONE UNNAMED
FBI ATTORNEY SENT AN INSTANT
MESSAGE TO A FELLOW FBI
EMPLOYEE, LOOK AT THIS.
I'M CLINGING TO SMALL
POCKETS OF HAPPINESS IN THE
DARK TIMES OF THE
REPUBLICAN'S DESTRUCTION.
AND FOLLOWING THE ELECTION,
THE SAME FBI ATTORNEY SENT
AN INSTANT MESSAGE THAT
SAID, QUOTE:  I'M NUMB WITH
A FELLOW EMPLOYEE RESPONDING
I CAN'T STOP CRYING.
NOW, PRIMARY TO THE ELECTION
IN SEPTEMBER OF 2016, ONE
FBI AGENT INVOLVED IN AN
INSTANT MESSAGE CONVERSATION
WHERE THEY ATTACKED
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
SUPPORTERS, THEIR WORDS, NOT
MINE, I DON'T USE IT
RETARDED.
AND BY THE WAY THAT'S ONLY
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
IG IS REFERRED FIVE FBI
EMPLOYEES FOR INVESTIGATION
AFTER UNCOVERING THEIR
EXTREME POLITICAL BIAS AND
GET THIS:  HOROWITZ'S
OVERALL CONCLUSION SAID NO
PREVAILING BIAS AT THE FBI
AND ITS ACTIONS IN THE
CLINTON AND TRUMP
INVESTIGATIONS REALLY,
MR. HOROWITZ?
YOU DON'T SEE THAT AS
POLITICAL BIAS?
WHAT DO YOU CALL EVERYTHING
YOU JUST ROUTERRED?
IT'S ALL POLITICAL AND LOOK
AT THIS IN THE IG REPORT
ALSO FOUND THAT FBI
EMPLOYEES RECEIVED OH, FREE
TICKETS TO SPORTING EVENTS
FROM WHO?
THE DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA.
SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS THEY
WENT ON GULF OUTINGS WITH
MEDIA REFS.
THEY WERE TREATED TO DRINKS
AND FOOD BY REPORTERS.
BECAUSE OF EVERYTHING WE
JUST SHOWED YOU, THAT REPORT
CONCLUDED THE COMEY, PAGE,
STRZOK AND OTHERS SEVERELY
DAMAGED THE REPUTATION OF
THE FBI.
HERE IS WHAT CURRENT FBI
DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER WRAY
SAID ABOUT ALL OF THESE
DAMNING FINDINGS, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> I TAKE THIS REPORT VERY
SERIOUSLY AND WE ACCEPT ITS
FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THOUGH
TO NOTE WHAT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL DID NOT FIND.
THIS REPORT DID NOT FIND ANY
EVIDENCE OF POLITICAL BIAS
OR IMPROPER CONSIDERATIONS
ACTUALLY IMPACTING THE
INVESTIGATION UNDER REVIEW
THE REPORT DOES IDENTIFY
ERRORS OF JUDGMENT,
VIOLATIONS OF OR EVEN
DISREGARD FOR POLICY AND
DECISIONS THAT AT THE VERY
LEAST WITH THE BENEFIT OF
HINDSIGHT WERE NOT THE BEST
CHOICES.
WE HAVE ALREADY START
STARTED TAKING STEPS TO
DIRECT THOSE ISSUES.
>> DIRECTOR WRAY READ THE
DOCUMENT.
THERE IS POLITICS ALL OVER
THAT DOCUMENT AND FOR YOU TO
SAY OTHERWISE IS NOT FAIR TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NOR IS
IT FAIR TO ALL THE GOOD,
HONEST HARD WORKING FBI
INDIVIDUALS RANK AND FILE
THAT PROTECT US EVERY DAY
THAT YOU DID RIGHTLY TALK
ABOUT TODAY.
A GOOD START, ALL RIGHT,
DIRECTOR WRAY.
WELL THAT WOULD BE FIRING
PETER STRZOK.
DOES HE STILL HAVE A JOB
DESPITE EVERYTHING YOU JUST
SAW?
PETER STRZOK REMAINS ON THE
PAYROLL OF THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
AND MEANWHILE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WAS ALSO
FEATURED IN THE REPORT.
FOOTNOTE PAGE 89 READS,
QUOTE:  PRESIDENT BARACK
OBAMA WAS ONE OF 13
INDIVIDUALS WITH WHOM
CLINTON HAD DIRECT CONTACT
USING HER CLINTON MAIL.COM
ACCOUNT.
THAT INFORMATION BREAKS WITH
OBAMA'S INITIAL CLAIMS THAT
HE LEARNED OF CLINTON'S
PRIVATE EMAIL FROM THE MEDIA
REPORTS.
WHAT WERE THEY PROTECTING?
REMEMBER THEY CHANGED THAT
TO SAY HIGH RANKING OFFICIAL
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AT
THIS TIME LORETTA LYNCH WAS
ALSO TAKING TO TASK IN THE
REPORT FOR INFAMOUS TARMAC
MEETING WITH BILL CLINTON
JUST BEFORE THEY CAME TO A
DECISION IN JUNE OF 2016.
THE REPORT STATES, QUOTE:
LYNCH'S FAILURE TO RECOGNIZE
THE APPEARANCE PROBLEM
CREATED BY FORMER PRESIDENT
CLINTON'S VISIT AND ERROR IN
JUDGMENT.
OKAY, 45 MINUTES TALKING
ABOUT GRANDCHILDREN, I WILL
BUY THAT FIRST, HERE IS HOW
CHAIRMAN GOWDY AND GOODLATTE
RESPONDED TO THIS ENTIRE
REPORT EARLIER TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT A DARK DAY IT IS
FORTH FBI AND DOJ, TWO
INSTITUTIONS OUR COUNTRY
DESPERATELY NEEDS.
WE DESPERATELY HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
THEM.
AND THIS LEVEL OF BIAS AND
ANIMUS NOT ONLY DID THEY
WANT TO STOP THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, HE WANTED TO STOP
>> YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
PETER STRZOK.
>> PETER STRZOK THE FBI
AGENT WHO WAS ON HILLARY
CLINTON'S INVESTIGATION AND
ARGUABLY THE LEAD RUSSIA
INVESTIGATOR.
NOT ONLY WANTED TO STOP HIS
CAMPAIGN BUT ONCE HE WON GOT
ON THE MUELLER PROBE BECAUSE
HE WANTED TO IMPEACH HIM.
>> THIS REPORT SHOWS THAT
THERE WAS SPECIAL TREATMENT
GIVEN TO HILLARY CLINTON IN
THE INVESTIGATION OF HER
CASE.
THERE IS NOT STANDARD
PROCEDURES FOLLOWED IN
INVESTIGATING HER AND THERE
WAS SPECIAL TREATMENT GIVEN.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THIS
WAS NOT PROPER PROCESS AND
THE REPORT SHOWS TIME AND
TIME AGAIN HOW DIRECTOR
COMEY AND OTHERS MADE
MISTAKES, ERRORS IN JUDGMENT
WERE DELIBERATE.
PEOPLE CAN DRAW THEIR OWN
CONCLUSIONS, BUT IT WAS
IMPROPERLY HANDLED.
>> Sean: LET ME SUM IT UP.
HILLARY CLINTON COMMITTED
FELONIES AND SHE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN CHARGED AND THESE
PEOPLE RAN INTERFERENCE FOR
HER.
WE HAVE AMPLE EVIDENCE OF
BIAS CORRUPTION, POLITICS,
MISCONDUCT AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF THE FBI.
THE DOJ AND NOW THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION YET WON'T
CALL THIS FOR WHAT IT IS
MR. HOROWITZ?
YOU CAN'T CONCLUDE THE
OBVIOUS BIAS IMPACTED SOME
AT THE YOU WERE ECHELON OF
THE FBI AND THEIR WORK AND
THEIR SO-CALLED
INVESTIGATION?
WHY?
BECAUSE THAT WOULD TAINT THE
PHONY RUSSIA CO-COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION WE CANNOT HAVE
A TWO TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM
IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA ONE FOR THE CLINTONS
AND ONE FOR TRUMP AND ONE
FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
WHILE THE FINDINGS OF THIS
REPORT ARE IMPORTANT, WE
MUST NOW DEMAND MORE.
THIS IS A FIRST STEP.
THERE HAS GOT TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE HAVE GOT TO HAVE A BETTER
SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT OR THE